five
welcome in welcome in everybody welcome
to another exciting edition of Market
takes you know I say that a lot I say
it's an exciting addition today is
exciting listen the market is moving in
some very interesting ways stocks have
gone up they've gone down bond prices
are moving all over the place the dollar
is doing what the dollar does I got you
listen I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me on Market takes I want to say
thank you for that
um we are breaking down everything that
happened with the release of this
morning's Consumer Price Index the CPI
report on inflation talking about what's
in the report what's happening what's
going on we're going to be breaking all
that down of course we're going to be
talking about the market reaction uh
we're going to be talking about the
current environment right everything
that led us into the CPI report today as
well as what's going on right now and
what we can expect to come and of course
what comes next what reports you need to
be watching for what fed speakers all
that good stuff to look out for in the
future so without further Ado without or
chitter chatter let's get into what
matters I'd like to do a little rhyming
here and there listen what the CPI
report said if you haven't heard by now
uh inflation Rose 6.5 year over year and
declined by 0.1 percent month over month
now this continues the falling trend of
inflation that we have seen over the
past six months as you're seeing right
now on your screen CPI peaked in June
that's that big let High number you see
the rapid increase up through June's 9.1
percent reading and then a decline ever
since then so what's got the market so
excited or what has had the market so
excited really over the past month but
specifically over the past week
has been this declining trend of
inflation and expectations for the FED
to slow its role and kind of you know
really sort of shift to a different and
more easy stance so just wanted to throw
that up there to illustrate what we have
seen and what the current and consistent
trajectory has been for CPI and that has
been for the inflation numbers to come
down and we saw that continue this month
with that 6.5 reading after November 7.1
percent reading but again keep in mind
we are still very far away from the
fed's two percent Target the FED wants
inflation at two percent as of December
it was at 6.5 percent that's still a big
difference you have to keep that in mind
a lot of folks in the markets not really
seem to think about that
um the reading came in right on the
screws this is what economists had
expected from the year over year to the
month over month at least the economist
surveyed by Dow Jones some of those
other economists they got it wrong but
the Dow Jones Market economists have
predicted 6.5 percent year over year and
negative point one percent month over
month also the core inflation readings
are Dow Jones economists had predicted
six or I'm sorry 5.7 percent uh year
over year and 0.3 percent month over
month that's the core when you strip out
food and energy which those prices can
or those rates can move a lot up and
down you strip those out you get the
core prices that was an increase of 0.3
percent month over month and five point
seven percent year over year again right
on the screws exactly what economists
had predicted listen those numbers tell
you part of the story The Big Picture
takeaway when we're talking about what
matters to the market what matters to
the economy what matters to the Federal
Reserve is we are seeing Goods inflation
decline consistently and really turn
lower but we are seeing Services
inflation rise higher and that matters
for a couple reasons now number one
Goods inflation had really driven the
cost up and driven this inflation that
we had seen up higher that's used cars
new cars things like good goods and and
those sorts of things gas and all that
that really drove the the wave that we
saw of inflation up to that nine percent
rate that we saw in June that's been
coming down very consistently but what
we have also seen is a pickup in
Services inflation and services make up
about 80 percent of the economy so
overwhelmingly most of what drives the
US economy forward is services and we
are seeing inflation there Rise as Goods
inflation is coming down so that is a
big concern for the Federal Reserve
we've seen Fed chair Jerome Powell
really point out that Services inflation
component especially Services inflation
minus housing and so we're going to talk
a little bit about that Goods decline
Goods decline by 1.1 percent uh on the
month and that's about 39 of the overall
CPI Services make up 61 of the CPI and
that was up 0.6 and 7.5 percent on the
year so listen Services minus shelter
was point four percent so we're seeing
those Services numbers start to inch up
and get higher Services overall was up
about seven percent year over year and
point five percent month over month
that's actually an increase from
November so what we've seen overall CPI
declining because Goods prices are
declining so much and falling service is
inflation which makes up a larger
portion of the economy a bigger
percentage of the economy those prices
have been increasing kind of
consistently and that's a bit worrisome
so that's why you're seeing some of this
pull push and pull in the markets with
prices kind of jumping then falling then
falling then jumping and investors
aren't really sure what to make of this
report we're going to try to break it
down a little bit more for you here this
has kind of been a thing where you know
the pandemic really pushed up Goods
prices everyone was sitting at home you
couldn't do much you couldn't go out
couldn't go out to eat couldn't go to
the bar you know a lot of those Services
weren't really being used you weren't
going to the barbershop things like that
well as the economy is Shifting now back
into gear folks still have a lot of that
excess savings pent up from those
stimulus checks you know the stemi uh
from a lot of those funds that went out
for the child care tax credits things
like that that government money that
enhanced unemployment that folks got and
now instead of spending it on just
buying stuff from Amazon sitting at home
on the couch you know you're buying
things on your phone doing things like
that well now they're going out they're
getting an extra haircut they're going
getting the more expensive haircut maybe
taking expensive trips things like that
and we're seeing those Services prices
start to rise as good prices are coming
down and so one thing you may not be
seeing is this increase in Services
prices the FED has really pointed that
out and that could give them some more
ammo to raise rates and to keep rates
high as they've said they plan to do so
the FED has really been clear they don't
plan to cut rates at all this year 2023
the market is very clear that they
expect the FED to cut rates this year
and so you've got this kind of back and
forth energy down four and a half
percent in the report food up 0.3
percent month over month food at home up
0.2 percent the food index up 10.4
percent but again that's slower than it
was in November and so did this
declining Pace anyway the shelter index
which is the big one that's housing
that's the piece of this that you know
really is is getting I think missed by a
lot of the Bulls out there shelter index
is still Rising a lot of folks have said
well shelter is a lagging indicator
really most folks sign a new lease at
the beginning of the year and then those
prices just kind of get filtered into
the index as you go on that's correct
but that doesn't mean you should ignore
what's happening with shelter that's
rent prices owner the owner equivalent
price is basically what you're paying on
your mortgage and or owner equivalent
rent if you were renting from someone
who owns a house you are paying owner
equivalent rent so the shelter index was
up from November actually increased and
was near the highest it's been or the
highest it was for all of 2022. uh we
know shelter is a lagging indicator but
it is still high and the Federal Reserve
wants to make sure they quash inflation
so shelter is going to be a big part of
what they look at anyway let's move on
to the market and what the market
reaction was to this data because we
have seen really indexes move across the
board in particular the stock market as
we look out right now the Dow has just
turned positive really we saw futures
for the Dow Spike higher then we saw
them go lower now they've just moved up
to kind of positive and you're seeing a
rebound again there's been this push and
pull you know some of the Bulls bought
ahead of time before the market opened
and you saw futures for the Dow the s p
the NASDAQ really Spike higher and then
once the market opened you saw him just
kind of come crashing down a lot of
folks selling their stocks and now
you're seeing the Dow come back up to
about flat on the day the NASDAQ is
still down about 0.6 percent as s p down
about point four percent you're probably
going to see a lot of that as we go
forward throughout the rest of the day
because you've got two different tacks
you can take you can say okay
inflation's coming down if I look at the
headline numbers we're seeing a positive
trend for inflation that means the FED
can chill out lay back not do as much or
you can say you know what I dug into the
numbers I see the shelter number I see
Services uh this is bad let me sell and
you're seeing a lot of that in the stock
market right now as we look out in the
bond market I think that's been very
interesting because the longer dated
notes the 10-year and the 30-year
government bonds those yields are
actually Rising you're seeing higher
yields which means expectations for more
inflation more growth things like that
and we did see again initially those
bond yields went down Bond investors
were buying bonds looking bullish about
the future now those prices are going
back up so you're seeing a little bit of
this back and forth really across
markets as we look out across the curve
you know you saw again yields come down
now they're kind of rising back up as we
look at the currency Market you've got
the Euro and the dollar the dollar Index
was really down to start the day
immediately after the release of the CPI
report we're seeing a lot of that
momentum come off and one thing I want
to point out especially right now that I
think is particularly important is
Commodities we're seeing oil Futures up
by about one percent some of that
momentum coming off but oil up about one
percent right now gold had been up as
much as one percent now of about point
three percent silver has been up as much
as three percent now up about 1.3
percent natural gas up five percent big
day for natural gas but Dr copper which
is a big tell on what folks expect for
the US economy is down by about point
six percent
um we're seeing that big increase in
gold and a commensurate increase that
had been in Copper until today I think
the move in Copper is very telling tells
us there are some worries about the
state of the U.S economy and what this
could mean going forward definitely
going to want to watch copper going to
want to watch gold because those two
usually mean it move in opposite
directions they have been over the past
month or so moving together usually gold
means folks are bearish they're worried
they think interest rates are going to
decline because you don't get paid any
interest on gold so holding gold is
something you do instead of holding
bonds and if bonds are paying a lot you
don't want to hold gold well now gold is
rising back up it's near 1900 uh 1900
per ounce and that's the highest gold
has been in quite some time check my
sheet here it's the highest it's been
since April of last year so big move uh
in gold and we're seeing copper kind of
decline it had been up over four dollars
a pound for the first time since June
watch copper and gold those I think are
going to be big in terms of what's going
on in the markets look let's talk about
the overall current environment that
we're in the FED is expected to raise
rates no one's got any question about
that the big question is just by how
much so as we throw up this fomc the FED
funds rate right and this is the Fed
funds rate what the fed's doing we talk
about the FED raising interest rates
we're talking about what's on your
screen right now as you can see interest
rates the highest they have been at any
time in the last 15 years we go we go
all the way back to 2013 or I'm sorry
yeah we go we go all the way back to
2013 on this chart to just give you an
ID of 10 years this is well above where
we've been at any time in the past
decade and you see the FED funds rate
going up there near four and a half
percent in a range of 4.25 to 4.5
percent and we are well above where
we've been anytime in the past decade
that's important because that has a big
effect on the economy folks who have
started a business in the past 10 years
have never seen this environment folks
who are running business folks who are
making purchasing decisions who started
in the past 10 years have never seen
anything like this keep that in mind
when you're talking about business and
the outlook for the economy moving
forward so just wanted to make sure that
you saw that and wanted to put that up
there on the screen for you so you're
able to look at it a big thing has been
expectations for what the Federal
Reserve will do next we know they've
already raised this much expectations a
month ago had been about 50 50 you saw
51 percent of investors in the FED fund
Futures Market predicting the FED would
raise 50 basis points you saw about 49
of investors predicting they raised by
25 basis points that has flipped and now
you've got about 91 percent of investors
predicting that the increase is going to
be just 25 basis points and you've got
just nine percent of investors
predicting it's gonna be 50 basis points
so after today's CPI report those
numbers moved well in the direction of
25 basis points investors strongly
predict the FED is going to slow down
significantly remember we were raising
75 basis points which is three times as
much just a few months ago now we slowed
down to 50 in December and now investors
are expecting 25 basis point move at the
fed's next meeting January 31st and then
they'll talk to us on February 1st at
the press conference when we look at the
recent data that we've got cotton on
these reports the jobs report showed
significant lower hourly earnings and
slowing hours that's a trend for
inflation to come down we saw a decline
in the employment Trend index for the
third month in a row again suggesting
the labor market is cooling the FED has
really pointed the labor market and said
too many jobs too much hiring too much
of this what normally would be good
things is going on in the economy the
New York fed conservative consumer
expectations so declining one-year
inflation expectations to the lowest
since July 2021 people think inflation
is going to come down and what we have
seen from the joltz report the job
opening and labor turnover survey now I
want to throw something on the screen
here just so you can see exactly what
we're talking about Fed chair Jerome
Palace talked a lot about well there's
so many job openings and there's two
times many job openings or two job
openings for every unemployed person
look at this chart you go all the way
back to the beginning of this chart
which was 2001 and you see that we had
now ever seen this before where there
was this many more job openings for this
many unemployed people the unemployment
rate is very low but there are lots of
job openings about 10.45 million job
openings according to the last job
report and only about 6 million
unemployed people so not quite at two to
one but as you see it's kind of starting
to come down there at the end so as
we've been moving forward there have
been a declining number of job openings
number of unemployed people has stayed
steady but that unemployment or those
job openings have been coming down and
that's what the Federal Reserve wants to
see we're also seeing slowing prices in
the employment and recent purchasing
managers index those is those are signs
that the economy is starting to cool and
worry some for some folks could be
moving towards recession so that's the
overall environment we've seen the FED
has said look we're willing to withstand
a recession if it means getting
inflation under control and that's
really what a lot of the data is telling
us we're moving away from this economic
expansion where things are booming and
we moving back towards a cooling Perhaps
Perhaps recessionary environment the FED
is saying they're okay with that we are
going to get a number of fed speakers
today
I want to highlight a few of those that
we'll see coming out today and just so
we've already heard from Philadelphia
fed president Patrick Harker he spoke at
8 45 a.m he said that he supports a move
to 25 basis points that's that much
slower or the normal pace of rate hikes
but Patrick Harker is not a voter he
doesn't actually get a vote fed St Louis
fed President James Bullard he is going
to talk at 11 30. you'll want to tune in
for that and the Richmond fed president
Thomas Barkin also not a voter he speaks
at 12 40. James Bullard is a voter he
has a vote on the committee he has
gotten very hawkish meaning he favors
higher rates to quell inflation uh his
his remarks will be very well followed
by the market if you're in the market if
you're an investor you're going to want
to watch what uh what St Louis fed
president Bullard has to say at 11 30
a.m all right listen moving forward we
all want to know what comes next what
comes next right what's the next shoe to
drop we will get the University of
Michigan consumer sentiment index that
is released on Friday tomorrow
MLK day we got to celebrate the good
Reverend doctor on Monday markets will
be closed uh you know do your thing go
out there like I said do something and
honor the good Reverend doctor make it a
day on not a day off as they like to say
then we get back into it Wednesday is
going to be retail sales and the
producer price index AKA wholesale
prices AKA what businesses are paying we
will be right here on Market takes on
Wednesday breaking that down giving you
all the information everything you need
to know so be there or be a
that's a square don't do it and then we
get existing home sales on Friday after
that so we'll be right back here on
Market takes in a little less than a
week we hope that you will be with us
and I know you could be anywhere I hope
you'll be right here with us that's
going to do it for us right now but
thank you so much for being with us I'm
your host Dion we're Bowen this has been
Market takes and we will see you next
time